We are here.
Good afternoon.
"We are here with Gerardo camps,
that as we all know,
has been the Secretary of State for Social Security
western part of the Toledo Pact.
And you brought here and counted.
You have asked the socialist government
that does not break the single social security fund.
What does that mean?
It is very simple,
than any Spaniard,
regardless of where you come in and where you go
to receive the retirement pension,
puts the one that corresponds to it
and the same according to their circumstances.
So that means that the Basques,
that the Basque pensioners are in 2nd place at the moment.
have 1/2 of €1,700.
Far behind,
for example,
Andalusian pensioners.
The Canary Islanders,
who number around €1,000,
will they benefit
according to the rest of the Spaniards
if the single box breaks?
Yes,
they will have even higher pensions,
despite the fact that their pensions are already
are higher than those of other pensioners.
Hey,
from the popular party
we're not going to let,
are we?
Certainly not.
Thank you